You've probably purchased something over
the phone or online at some point in
your life.
After giving your credit card information
and any and pain for the item it's
shipped to you.
Often that shipment contains,
in addition to whatever you
bought a document containing
terms and conditions of
the sale.
Such documents often include warranty
information and information about dispute
resolution such as an arbitration clause.
Are you bound by the
terms of that document?
Today we're going to compare two cases.
The first decided by the seventh circuit
in 1997 the second by the District
Court for Kansas three years later that
addressed this question but reached
opposite conclusions in both hill and Clo.
Check.
The plaintiffs purchase computers from
the defendant company over the phone and
received shipments containing the products
that offered the shipments contained
as well.
A list of terms in hill.
Those terms gave the purchaser 30 days
in which to return the computer if they
didn't agree to the terms and
included in arbitration clause.
Enclosed check the terms declared that
the purchasers of retaining the computer
for more than five days after the date
of delivery constituted acceptance of the
terms and similarly included
an arbitration clause.
The plaintiffs in both cases sued gateway
after performance problems with the
computers.
In both cases,
the company claimed the plaintiffs were
bound by the arbitration clause in the
terms and conditions because
the plaintiffs kept their
computers for longer than
the time period set forth in
those terms and conditions.
Hill was decided by
judge Frank Easterbrook.
Easterbrook had previously issued an
influential opinion in pro CD versus
Zeidenberg,
a case that presented similar issues
and which shaped the judge's opinion in
hill in pro CD.
Easterbrook held that terms inside a
shipment of software contractually bound
consumers who use the software after
they had an opportunity to read the terms
and reject them by returning the product.
The same logic applied Easterbrook said
in hill crucial to the decision was the
judge's understanding of when the contract
between Hill and gateway was actually
formed.
The judge denied that the contract was
formed when hill paid for the computer
and gateway delivered it,
which would mean that the terms were
not part of the original agreement.
Instead relying on the principal
derived from UCC to tool for that,
a vendor as master of the offer may invite
acceptance by conduct and may propose
limitations on the kind of conduct that
constitutes acceptance a buyer make,
except by performing the acts the
vendor proposes to treat as acceptance.
Easterbrook concluded that gateway
invited a hill to accept by keeping the
computer after receiving
the terms and conditions.
The arbitration clause was thus part of
the contract and bound the plaintiffs.
It didn't matter that the plaintiffs
didn't read the terms because they had the
opportunity and responsibility to do so.
The District Court of Kansas disagreed
it explicitly rejected hill when it
decided clo check versus gateway.
The court in Kansas stated at the outset
of it's opinion that the fact that Clo
check paid gateway for a computer and
received that product from gateway quote
clearly demonstrates a contract
for the sale of a computer unquote.
It took issue with Eastern
Brooks categorization of
the defendant as the quote
master of the offer and his conclusion
that gateway conditioned acceptance on
the plaintiff's assent to the term
and conditions in the shipment.
The defendant had offered no evidence
that either of these things was the case
more significantly.
The district court argued that the
seventh circuit had incorrectly concluded
that the UCC section two two oh
seven did not apply to these cases.
UCC Two two oh seven is the famous battle
of the forms provision that we just
spoke about in the last class as we
just discussed in this textile unlimited
case.
Two Two oh seven provides if a contract
is formed with a confirmation that
includes additional terms under
subsection one then that operates as an
acceptance.
The additional terms are to be construed
as proposals for a additions to the
contract unless both parties are merchants
as the opinion notes.
The plaintiff was not a merchant,
so under Kansas interpretation of the UCC
and this is the UCC section two two oh
seven, if either party is not a
merchant, the additional terms,
our proposals for additions to the
contract and do not become part of the
contract unless the original
offer war expressly agrees.
The court concluded that the fact,
uh,
the clo check kept the computer for
more than five days was not sufficient
evidence that he expressly
agreed to the additional terms.
And for that reason the plaintiff
was not bound by those terms,
including the arbitration clause.
Easterbrook provided policy justifications
for his holding asserting that
writing a provides benefits for both
sides of commercial transaction.
Customers as a group are better off
when vendors skip costly and ineffectual
steps such as telephone,
recitations and use instead a
simple approve or returned device.
It's probably true that consumers would
not want to sit through and over the
phone recitation of pages of terms
and conditions before completing the
purchase. But as Easter fair to
suggest, these are the only options.
A footnote and Khloe check
offered another possibility.
It said quote,
the court is mindful of the practical
considerations which are involved in
commercial transactions but it's not
unreasonable for a vendor to clearly
communicate to a buyer at the time of
sale either the complete terms of the sale
or the fact that the vendor will propose
additional terms as a condition of sale
if that be the case.
What if the gateway representative on
the phone and on the phone call at which
the purchase took place simply inform the
consumer that the forthcoming computer
shipment would contain important terms
and conditions that gateway considered a
part of the contract.
These cases provide a good introduction
to the concept of the rolling contract.
Such contracts are formed over time with
one party providing terms in batches,
some before a given item is
ordered and others later,
but often the latter batch of terms are
unlikely to be read and will be accepted
by conduct.
Is it fair to make increasing use of such
contracts when the offer war is aware?
The terms probably will
never be seen or understood
despite the disagreement
we see in these two cases.
The seventh circuit's ruling in
hill is no longer controlling,
at least over cases governed
by Illinois law. In 2006,
the Illinois Supreme Court decided in
razor versus Hyundai Motor that a warranty
containing a disclaimer
of consequential damages,
which is which was in the owner's manual
of a glove compartment of the car.
The plaintiff in the case had purchased,
was not part of the car sale contract
because it wasn't made available to the
purchaser at or before
the purchase of the car,
the district court for the
northern district of Illinois.
I recognize that the razor decision
was not was now controlling rather than
hill,
uh,
in a separate case to Hylo
versus apple computer.
So what have we learned?
We were introduced to rolling contracts
in particular to accept a return terms
that accompany customer ordered goods.
We saw two different cases laid
out opposite lines of reasoning,
the first enforcing the acceptor
or return terms, the latter,
rejecting them and exploring policy
arguments and potential compromises for
these kinds of transactions.
And once again,
we see that generally it's a good idea
to read carefully the documents that come
with your purchases.